then there's this guy Ben Ryan who he is
an NBC guy we did we confirm that he's
an NBC guy uh look at this tweet I mean
is this just unbelievable NBC has id'd
the Nashville school shooter as Audrey
Hale 28 who identifies as transgender
and had no previous criminal record
Nashville is home to the Daily wire a
hub of anti-trans activity by Matt Walsh
Ben Shapiro and Michael Knowles
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh and Michael
Knowles had nothing to do with this the
daily wire being in Nashville had
nothing to do with this we will find out
more about the medication this person
was on the ideology that this person was
following but Ben Shapiro and Michael
Knowles and Matt Walsh never said if you
like us or dislike us or anything else
you should take the law into your own
hands and kill people
this is a mental health issue guys it is
a mental health issue guys but look
here's how the USA Today covered this
police on Monday afternoon said that the
shooter was a transgender man officials
had initially misidentified the gender
of the shooter do you see how stupid
this is it is so I don't care and no one
in their right mind cares about the
gender of this person right now right
it's going to become political because
they've they've forced this trans stuff
on everybody but you see where the media
is worried about oh my god did we
misgender the the murderer insane
[Music]